[Musique]
alexis vient d'obtenir son permis de
conduire il demande tout de suite d'en
profiter le doute son père papa accepte
ah oui alexis est tellement fier mais
alors qu'il traversait une intersection
un véhicule rue leçon fut rouge et
vienne frappées alexis sent confusément
que ce qui vient de se passer
notre plaisir à papa il a vu juste en
plus dans le père téléphone à l'assureur
celui ci refuse de le dédommager au
complet parce que le père n'a pas pensé
à ajouter son fils comme conducteur
occasionnel la logique de l'assureur
s'il avait su qu alexis conduire l auto
il aurait augmenté la prime de 25% parce
que alexis est un jeune garçon
inexpérimentés l'assureur décide donc de
réduire de 25% le montant qu'il va payer
pour son accident
un papa de payer le reste le fin mot de
l'histoire
vous avez un nouveau conducteur fringant
appelé d'abord l'assureur et retenez
votre poulain en attendant